كانت شبكه سي او عفوا ان بي سي نقلت في
وقت سابق عن مسؤولين امريكيين ان الرد
العسكريه الامريكيه على مقتل الجنود
الثلاثه قد يستمر على مدى ايام او اسابيع
وقالت شبكه ان بي سي نقلا عن هؤلاء
المسؤولين ان الرئيس بايدن سال فريقه
للامن القومي ضمن المشاوره الخاصه بالرد
العسكري بشان ما اذا كان الرد سيعرض
محادثات اطلاق سراح محتجزين في قطاع غزه
للخ وقالت انه قرر المضي قدما في اجراءات
الرد بعد ان قلل فريقه من المخاوف بشان
المحادثات لمزيد من المتابعه والتحليل
انضم الينا من واشنطن الدكتور خليل
العناني استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه دكتور خليل اهلا بك على شاشه
الجزيره مره اخرى يعني لنبدا بالبيان
الاخير الذي تحدث عن
ان فريق بايدن ومستشاريه اخبرو بان بانه
يمكنه المضي قدما في في في هذه الضربات
الى اي مدى توافق على فكره ان ضربات كهذه
وتصعيدا كهذا لن يؤثر بالفعل عمليا على اي
صفقه محتمله لتبادل
الاسرى صباح الخير نشوان لك والساده
المشاهدين انا اعتقد لابد ان نفصل بين كلا
الامرين بين ان هذه الضربات في ظني وفي
رايي وفي اعتقادي ضربات
تكتيكيه سيكولوجيه بالاساس وليست ضربات
استراتيجيه هدفها قلب المعادله في المنطقه
الع العربيه هي ضربات تكتيكيه جزء منها
استعراضي باستهداف 85 موقع في سبع اماكن
داخل العراقه سوريه هدفها بالاساس اعاده
تثبيت قواعد الاشتباك القائمه على الردع
والردع المضاد نتيجه لقيام بعض الجماعات
المواليه لايران بقتل ثلاثه جنود امريكيين
وصبت 40 لكن ايضا الرد الامريكي لم يتجاوز
الخطوط الحمراء فيما يتعلق اولا بالضرب
داخل ايران كما كان يطالب بعض الكور داخل
واشنطن وفي نفس الوقت وقت حتى هذه اللحظه
ليس هناك خسائر كبيره من ناحيه الوزن
النوعي لمن تم استهدافهم حتى هذه اللحظه
لم نسمع عن استهداف قيادات كبيره سواء في
الحرس الثوري الايراني او في فلك القدس
وبتالي هي ضربات بالاساس هدفها الرئيسي
فقط مجرد حفظ ماء الوجه الامريكي في راي
فيما يتعلق بموضوع صفقه الرهين هذا موضوع
ملف ملف نوعا ما مختلف لانه بيرتبط بظروف
اولا داخليه في اسرائيل مرتبط بظروف عمليه
على الارض في ظل فشل اسرائيل الى حد بعيد
في اطلاق سلاح الران عبر عمليه عسكريه
ومرتبط ايضا بحاله انهاك وتعب داخل امريكا
ورغبه واضحه في محاوله خفض التصعيد من
خلال صفقه رهائن قد تسفر بشكل او اخر عن
هدنه مؤقته قد تفضي في الامد المتوسط
لهدني او حتى ايقاف الحرب وبالتالي صعب ان
نخلط بين ملفين وانا اعتقد جزء رئيسي او
سبب رئيسي من زياره بلينكن التي من مفترض
ان تبدا السبت يعني اليوم بتوقيت المنطقه
وغدا بتوقيت واشنطن هي مرتبطه بشكل الاخر
بمحاوله ا انجاز صفقه الرهائن الهدنه
المؤقته سواء من خلال ما تم القول عنه ما
اشيح حول وجود شبه اتفاق اطاري تم وضعه في
اجتماع باريس الاسبوع الماضي بحضور
مسؤوليين مصريين واسرائيليين وامريكي
وقطريين او فيما يتعلق بما بطرح صفقه كبرى
متعلقه بالتطبيع في المنطقه العربيه مقابل
اعاده النظر في الحرب على قطاع غزه وربما
الدخول في مرحله من التهد قد تفضي الى وقف
اطلاق النار وبالتالي قد يبدو هناك علاقه
بين الملفين من ناحيه الجراند فيو يعني
الصوره الكبرى لكن بشكل تفصيلي لا هناك
فرق بين كذا الملفين طيب لكن هل يعني قد
نتوقع ان تستمر واشنطن من خلال التجارب
السابقه ان تستمر في عمليتها العسكريه
المحدوده هذه لكن هل ستستمر بنفس
الوتيره شوف بشكل عام حسب ما جاء اليوم
نشوان الحديث حول حم حمله عسكريه تستمر
الايام وبالتالي ليست فقط مجرد ضربات
مؤقته حمله عسكريه تستهدف مواقع للحرس
الثوري الايراني داخل سوريا وبعض الجماعات
والميليشيات التابعه له او على الاقل
القريبه منه في العراق وهذا الامر يشابه
بشكل او باخر ما يحدث الان في اليمن نحن
اذاء حمله عسكريه امريكيه بدعم بريطانيا
اوقات على اليمن منذ الحادي عش من يناير
الماضي يعني قبل حوالي 20 يوم من دلوقتي
وبالتالي انا اتوقع استمر هذه الحمله لكن
ايضا في اطار مضبوط ومنضبط بمعنى ايه
بمعنى عدم اتساع نطاق هذه الضربات كي تصل
مثلا الى حد ايران او اي كي تقوم باستهداف
مصالح ايرانيه مباشره هي في اطار كما قلت
قبل قليل ضربات تكتيكيه هدفها الحفاظ على
قواعد الاشتباك القديمه فيما يتعلق بالردع
وعدم توا عدم تجاوز الخطوط الحمراء سواء
الامريكيه او الايرانيه وبالتالي اتوقع ان
تستمر الفتره المقبله في اطار نفس المستوى
نفس الليفل فيما يتعلق باستهداف بعض منشات
الحرس الثوري الايراني بعض منص منصات
اطلاق الصواريخ بعض منصات اطلاق المسيرات
خاصه التي تستهدف بعض القوات الامريكيه
اللي موجوده في العراق سواء كان في قاعده
عين الاسد بالقرب من الانبار او قاعده
حرير بالقرب من مطار اربيل في كردستان
العراق او حتى في قاعده كونيكو في سوريا
وبالتالي اتوقع بالفعل استمار هذه الضربات
جزء منه رئيس نشوان متعلق بحفظ ماء الوجه
الامريكي وثانيا داخليا مرتبط بتقليل حجم
المزايدات من الجمهوريين على اداره بايدن
ا